[Applause]
the king will start the first full week
of his reign as the first weekend ended
in mourning
and at work
in parliament and in public
securing the political and popular
consent that his mother could take for
granted
his day will begin with an address to
the members of the lords and commons in
westminster hall before he travels to
scotland to rejoin the queen on her
final journey
it began in near silence birdsong the
accompaniment as the hearst left
balmoral on the slow road south
people lining the route to see the
coffin even in rural aberdeenshire along
with a guard of honour of tractors
and
horses in nearby baloter they counted
the queen and neighbor
it was quite overwhelming to be honest
i'm very very proud to be here
and very proud at the huge crowds that
have turned out to be so respectful and
to the queen and the royal family
i think it's the end of an era
you know it seems a very somber moment
it was important to just come along
today and
yeah just source of some respect and and
i thank you really
across the four nations there were
proclamations and pageantry
god saved
[Music]
three cheers and a gun salute for the
monarch
[Applause]
and in cardiff
and belfast
the king will visit them all in the
coming days but his first stop is
edinburgh where the coffin arrived
yesterday afternoon
today
king charles will lead a procession to
st giles cathedral where the queen's
body will lie in state for 24 hours
the start of a week of public display
here and in london
after a final night among family
in the privacy
of the palace of holyrood house
paul kelso sky news